in my group were very interested in uh
basil cognition in general and diverse
intelligence more more broadly um really
understanding what are the properties
the the protoc cognitive properties of
this new model system what what do they
know how to do do they can they form
memories can they learn from their
environment can they um do they have
preferences about different uh different
Lifestyles or different outcomes that
that can befall them and so on none of
this is known we've made no claims yet
as to their level on the sort of you
know the spectrum of of cognition we
have no idea where they where they fit
but the one thing I know for sure is
that we we don't guess we have to do
experiments and find out